what are your thoughts on prenups i'm
all for it do you have a prenup
absolutely i'm all for it i think you
need to have it uh and let me tell you
what what it did to our relationship
when we have a prenup so do you have one
yourself or i do okay so let me tell you
what it did for us so here's what
happened family calls uh hey babe such
and such happened with my mother's
cousins nephews wife whoever it is and i
want to build this guy i need a thousand
dollars here's 8 000 babe and you go to
work and you're kind of bitter at your
wife you're like i don't even know who
this person is why the hell are we
bailing this person out eight thousand
dollars
hey babe you know this person died and
we kind of have to help with the funeral
final expense they don't have any money
eighteen thousand dollars
okay here's 18 000
when those things happen two three four
five times you're eventually a little
bit annoyed
she says i want to buy that new chanel
purse
how much babe well it's up a little bit
twelve thousand dollars
okay go buy the chanel purse somebody
may say what's wrong with that what's
wrong with this no problem everybody has
this different set of guidelines i like
where we have
your money my money our money
this is your money you want to buy that
chanel purse buy it with your money
if i want to buy that purse for you i'll
buy it with my money so you know i
bought it with my money it's a form of i
bought it with mine rather than our
money okay if we have something that
we're doing for our kids and ourselves
which is us team us this is our money
if you want to spend fifty thousand
dollars on your nephew or your niece you
don't even need to ask me because you're
using whose money your money i notice
that minimize arguments to the point
where
no one's being judged no one said why
are you buying that purse why are you
doing this why are you buying that why
no
so we go to louis vuitton when this
thing gets set up and she says
uh can i see that purse and can i see
that purse
yes
how much is that 35. how much is that
45. she looks at me i want to buy these
and i look at it i'm like
okay i'm buying it with my money
okay go for it what if she doesn't have
money though what if she is stay-at-home
mom she's not having income but she
wants let's just say the ten thousand
dollars first how much do you make
how much do you make say so give me that
scenario but give me the case study with
the husband what does the husband make
gosh let's just let's just say a million
bucks a year if he makes a million bucks
a year and you know you're going to set
up a prenuptial government to protect
you
create a porsche an account where you
put money in where she can do whatever
she does without asking you
that's the account so whatever she wants
to buy without ask because i'm in the
business of minimizing arguments so for
example the biggest business issues i've
had in my life
is because i hurried a contract too much
without us getting those additional
three disclaimers in there
that if this happens here's how we exit
this and because we didn't have that it
caused an argument i don't want that so
let's spend a little bit more time with
the contract have your lawyers talk to
our lawyers let's take one more week and
let's see what else we want to add into
this what if it doesn't work between the
two of us it's apparently so let's just
say you all of some wake up one morning
you say pat i'm already worth 20 million
we're partners 50 50. i don't want to do
anything
i have the right to buy you out at the
market value at the time i can go find
finance and can buy you out but if
that's not in the agreement guess what
you can do but i don't want to sell i
just want to take my profits every year
now i hate you now we have issues so the
same thing with marriage if the guy is
making a million and you're worried
about the money she's spending put four
thousand dollars a month in an account
this is an account for you this is our
account expenses this is your account do
whatever you want to do with it that
prevents some of the arguments if you
enjoy this video i give a keynote a few
weeks ago in las vegas specifically on
the topic of cracking a code to content
creation if you've not seen it click
here to watch it take care everybody bye
[Music]